the new world
il dit
suis moi il faut que je commence quelque
chose et tu dois te promettre de patent
fia
tu voudrais bien attaché cette corde aux
tomates ail attention mais lâche pas
surtout
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
ce cas
je vais présenter aux autres
pensionnaires
zecs pile à l'heure mrgreen soyez le
bienvenu
il est invisible absolument pour dire
les choses simplement nous sommes disons
particulier c'est un gène récessif qui
se transmet dans certaines familles
laird c'est ça ma particularité comme
nos dons ne sont pas adaptés au monde
extérieur nous vivons dans des lieux
tels que c'est les psy pour nous
protéger nous créons une boucle
temporelle
une boucle enregistre les dernières 24
heures
renouveler la boucle permet de rester
ici à jamais je suis que vous étiez des
nôtres dès que vous êtes né il est temps
que vous découvriez de quoi vous êtes
capables mais moi je suis un garçon
ordinaire
non pas du tout son destin est de nous
protéger de quoi on les appelle les cpe
creux il me traquent depuis des siècles
à cause de ne pouvoir
crois moi vous ne pourrez pas nous
échapper
que décidera de faire peut tout changer
cette fois
promettez moi de rester avec eux je vous
charge leur protection
c'est promis
mon père dit que tout a déjà été
découverts pas tout non
le maire
vous a plu
soit ce cas
comment
et
nouveau coup ce qui n'est pas le cas
la belgique fait qu'ils possèdent
le présage t lorsque la différence
oui c'est le new moon et sky fit la
nouveauté de 1 0%
eich ouvrir votre avis
pourquoi
tchèque